many regular customers i spoke with
today didn't even know what happened
they came to do their weekend groceries
only to find their favorite supermarket
in rubble i'm in shock
rebecca gillian comes to the la bonita
on desert inn and eastern almost every
day and she thought saturday would be no
different i was looking for the story
and i said what is the sign that bonita
you know i know
i i was thinking i made the wrong turn
gillian was just there the day before
the collapse and says everything seemed
completely normal she was one of the
many customers who didn't know what
happened when she came out to the
supermarket saturday i thought i could
run parking and i say but i'm looking at
the sun and
i can see
a little bit right there
and many came by to see the destruction
for themselves it's just a good thing
that it didn't happen when we had the
mandates where they were social
distancing and
counting as the people were lined up
right here this would have been a
disaster shoppers taught me the grocery
store was very popular and the parking
lot was always full but now the collapse
is causing businesses nearby to feel the
impact of less foot traffic the whole
day traffic in and out
due to la bonita being open right now
it's been a little bit slow right now
there is still a fire danger state fire
officials have been on scene since
friday keeping an eye on the property
for any sparks that may come up
i was told by some workers on site that
they're going to every business in that
shopping complex to make sure their
structures are secure they also say
cleanup might start next week in the
newsroom victoria saha 8 news now